mientras la unión europea se enfrenta a
una crisis energética sin precedentes se
teme que la propaganda rusa pueda
provocar un conflicto de otro tipo
estamos empezando a ver la aparición en
las plataformas televisivas en los
discursos a veces de políticos a veces
de expertos pongo entre comillas que
difunden el mensaje ruso como creíble y
a veces incluso cuestionan la realidad
de los sórdidos acontecimientos que
están teniendo lugar en ucrania
el portavoz del gobierno francés olivier
dahán no dio nombres pero pareció
referirse en parte a los recientes
comentarios de ségolène royal la
candidata presidencial socialista en
2007 en el canal de noticias francés
bfmtv joya la acusó a ucrania de
utilizar propaganda de guerra y puso en
duda el bombardeo de un hospital de
maternidad en mariupol en marzo diciendo
se podría pensar que si hubiera la más
mínima herida un bebé sangrando en la
era de los teléfonos móviles habríamos
visto las imágenes pero de hecho esas
imágenes existen esta mujer embarazada
estaba entre quienes fueron rescatados
los escombros de elegancia no es el
único país que está preocupado alemania
y austria también están haciendo sonar
las alarmas sobre la desinformación rusa
esta guerra se desarrolla en diferentes
niveles
no solo con armas no solo con gas y
petróleo sino también con mentiras y
falsas narrativas
además de asumir la crisis energética
los líderes del bloque también están
enfrentando una guerra de mensajes con
los puntos de vista y la propaganda de
rusia expandiéndose en todo el
territorio de la unión europea